eyes full of terror mouths wide open the
terrible result of nastiness Andrey
Acosta the mayor of loot Sara says this
painting serves him not only as a
warning but as inspiration Romeo
quitting I don't have this painting to
scare people but so that I always see
what nastiness can actually do earlier
this year the mayor introduced an
ordinance banning offensive behavior in
lisara it's the first of its kind in
Italy it ordenanza believe I said I will
not I want to build a dam against the
degradation of social relations
especially on the Internet in social
media people are so nasty to each other
on social media on Facebook Instagram
Twitter etc you'd never see such
gratuitous behavior on the Piazza in the
bar or at the newspaper kiosk if people
were face to face
[Music]
the mayor has a lot to do in his small
town of 10,000 inhabitants between
Reggio Emilia and Mantua in northern
Italy but he hopes that loot Sara can
act as a bulwark against nastiness and
be a model for the whole country
[Music]
the mayor has a plan for punishing
offenders for example a compulsory trip
to the city's theatre he thinks culture
can serve as a weapon against the
potential collapse of society quando
saga no it doesn't change anything as
people vent their frustration angrily
and nastily their frustration remains
their problem stays and the whole
community suffers Andrea Costa also
recommends literature the municipal
library houses all the Italian classics
and much more all those who violate his
ordinance will have to read certain
books he chooses Costa was inspired by
cesare zavattini a screenwriter born in
lutes era who worked with the directors
Visconti antonioni and Fellini and had
an impact on Italian cinema for more
than three decades
la biblioteca de el italiano season 8
Sabatini I wanted to create a library of
the Italians that every Italian should
have in their home with books about
philosophy art literature and science
his idea was that only a well-rounded
general education could bring about
peaceful coexistence which in our le
persone
but not everyone in Lucero agrees
naturally the mayor's ordinance against
nastiness has its critics normal
citizens like me feel offended we are
decent people and if I go overboard a
bit once I'll be immediately punished
same room for you already but others are
happy about the new decree especially
when it comes to social media it's so
cowardly to not express opinions to
people's faces anyone can pretend to be
a hero I want a keyboard the mayor has
already taken one of these so-called
heroes to task
he was offensive on Facebook I contacted
the offender and called him to account
telling him what mistakes he'd made I
also invited him to read some of the
books which are listed in the ordinance
our phone conversation ended in a very
positive way mayor andreas Costa is
certain of his convictions and the
painting will remain as an inspiration
against his fight against nastiness
[Music]